des centaines de véhicules roulent les
uns collées sur les autres en direction
sud entre Shibu Gamo et Roberval un
bouchon monstre sur la route 67
normalement tranquille conséquence
directe d'un ordre d'évacuation lancée
hier soir ça a été là on est parti à 10h
hier soir que l'on arrive le trajet a
pris jusqu'à 8 heures soit plus du
double du temps habituel nous ramener
sur plus de 7000 évacuées environ 800
ont été accueillies épuisés à l'Arena de
Roberval j'ai pas encore dormi
de temps
le maire de Roberval a reçu les
résidents de shibuyamu en personne
durant la nuit le fait qu'on a été
accueilli par le maire de Roberval ici
donc du coup ça fait que toute la
fatigue a disparu un accueil chaleureux
avec des lits de la nourriture
la présence d'une pharmacie locale on
avait déjà communiqué avec les
pharmaciens propriétaires de
déformations
qui étaient déjà prête sur les réseaux
sociaux des offres de chambre de chalet
ou d'espace de camping pour les évacuer
on voulait vraiment une famille aussi
avec des enfants les pilotes les
mécaniciens là on a dû des défis de ce
côté-là est-ce qu'il y a un manque
Québec et la soeur suivent la situation
de près on prévoit pas de pluie
importante avant lundi soir prochain
donc ça veut dire que les 5 6 prochains
jours peut pas créer trop d'attente
d'être capable de retourner à la maison
une semaine au cours de laquelle les
équipes de la sopfe feu poursuivront
leurs interventions sur le terrain ici
Elisa l'art Radio-Canada Montréal